even as staff prepared top shop branches
to reopen on wednesday
their employer arcadia confirmed it was
entering administration
putting up to 13 and a half thousand
jobs at risk
and leaving workers like steve whose
identity we're protecting
facing a profoundly uncertain christmas
trying to now plan for for christmas
is is a lot more difficult going into
the new year again as well because
who knows we could be looking for for
more jobs and
it's you know it's it's really not it's
not nice at all it's not a nice feeling
it's very unsettling
arcadia brought to philip green and
knighthood and celebrity friends
but not immunity from changing retail
trends that weakened the company
or the pandemic that may have killed it
off sir phillips yacht was moored in
monaco today
a lifestyle funded by a 1.2 billion
pound dividend paid to his wife lady
tina
though it's thought they won't be
putting in the 30 million pounds arcadia
says it needs
should philip green be doing more to
save the company
you know you're sat there on a 100-foot
yacht
or whatever you know living the life of
luxury yet you're quite happy for it to
just go do you know what
i've got my money i don't really care
about anyone else now
that's how it feels and that's how it
comes across the tide
turned against the philip when he sold
bhs for a pound
leaving a 500 million pound hole in the
pension scheme
with arcadia's retirement fund at least
140 million pounds in deficit
mps are concerned about a repeat
[Applause]
[Music]
online fast fashion giant boohoo may be
tempted by the topshop brand
as administrators work to find buyers
and fraser's group owners of sports
direct remain
interested despite arcadia declining
their offer of a 50 million pound loan
but the loss is bound to be felt on the
high street
topshop has been clothing teenagers and
women for two
generations but it's paying for its
failure to keep up
with younger rivals and even if a buyer
can be found for this
it's prime asset the collapse of other
arcadia brands
will leave holes on high streets and in
retail parks
across the country in deeply challenging
times brands like burton dorothy perkins
evans and miss selfridge
will not be easily replaced all of them
have got a really important part they're
woven into the tapestry of
the high street as we know it but what's
really important is
all of them needed significant
investment to be able to enable them to
move with the times
and reconnect with not only their
existing audience but to find new
opportunities
christmas should be the best of time for
retailers for arcadia's staff
it may be the worst paul kelso sky news